this is a cardboard sir for cardboard
and water surely night-night mix we met
up with Mike Martinez to find out how
this idea got from the boardroom to the
beach
the idea of Licata more surfboards to me
came from my boss when he came in with
that idea
I really thought cool I thought it's
gonna be awesome
and the thing with these projects is you
start out with a ton of confidence and
then the realization of what you got
accomplished starts to kick in we
actually had to accomplish something
hasn't been done before so how did Mike
and the team create this novel surf or
cardboard may seem like a ridiculous
material to build a surfboard out of but
there's actually some great
characteristics about it it's
eco-friendly it's lightweight and it can
be surprisingly strong the cardboard
that Mike uses is a special packing
material called hexa comb and the hexa
comb is a bunch of these hexagon tubes
stacked next to each other it's flexible
in this direction but in this direction
and it's incompressible so you can stand
on it and you can be well assured that
it's not going to snap and that's why
this is a viable material for a
surfboard when we first thought of the
honeycomb that's when the lights lit up
on everyone every one of the media all
sudden boom instantly knew that's what
we want to do we want to use honeycomb
how did Mike manage to precisely cut
this flexible card Mike sprayed the hexa
cone cardboard with polyurethane spray
this had the effect of changing the
material properties making the cardboard
more rigid so it could be more easily
machined the polyurethane not only
stiffens the hexaco but it also makes it
waterproof so if the board springs a
leak
only that one tube will get wet and the
whole board doesn't flood after they've
shaped the board they cover it in the
standard surfboard scheme which is a
fiberglass sheet consisting of long thin
strands of glass suspended in a resin
the fiberglass seals off those hexa comb
tubes making this thing float but it has
an added effect of being transparent so
you can see through the hexa comb tubes
as well as the fiberglass so that means
you can see through the whole board that
moment when we first took took that
board out on the beach it's just joy it
just performed better than we at hope in
fact it kind of backfires on us because
now people
don't call because they want a box they
call me because they want to surf for